at 300 billion US Dollars this was the
most expensive World Cup ever held at 28
days it was also the shortest
this was the first World Cup held in the
Middle East and it was unashamedly Arab
the DJ at the opening night of the fan
Park briefly paused for evening prayers
fan zones were set up in Gaza Syria and
Yemen on the field the football was at
times Exquisite there have been moments
that will live long in the memory Saudi
Arabia's victory over Argentina
Ronaldo's exit in tears Harry Kane's
missed penalty
foreign
and of course Morocco's remarkable
advance to the semi-finals a huge moment
for the Arab world
[Applause]
[Music]
it didn't start smoothly though the eve
of the tournament I Am speech by FIFA
president Gianni Infantino when he took
aim at media coverage was tone deaf and
ill-judged two migrant workers died
during the tournament adding to an
already high death toll the qataris have
now admitted that as many as 500 died
building the World Cup infrastructure
but dismissed at least one death as a
part of life sure accidents happen just
not on the scale that they have in Qatar
This World Cup has been stained by human
rights abuses whether it's the abuses
against migrant workers where this
entire world cup has been built on or
the the lack of protections for LGBT
people
um as well as for women and what we have
seen is that the Qatari authorities
reluctance in providing for those
protections and even when they came they
came only for some
for the first time ever the tournament
was moved to the middle of a European
season to avoid the summer temperatures
but although often hot at the height of
day the heat was bearable early problems
with the digital ticketing system
prevented some supporters from getting
into stadiums
and some fans were refused entry simply
for wearing rainbow colors
FIFA broke its promise and made a late
decision to ban alcohol in stadiums but
the atmosphere at games was friendly and
good natured
not a single England fan was arrested
the World Cup will go down as a football
success undoubtedly but isn't that the
essence of sports washing using a
football tournament to cover up past
wrongdoing
FIFA and the host country said that
politics should stay out of sport but in
the end it was football that brought
about change in Qatar were it not for
the World Cup would labor laws have been
improved would LGBT plus rights have
been relaxed and would traditionally
rival Regional neighbors have come
together in the way they did
but Qatar is only part way on a journey
of Reform the legacy of this World Cup
is still being written
Alistair bunker Sky News in Doha